ces histoires je suis plié qu'est ce que
tu sais un camp de dollars tu parles
d'une fortune qu'est ce que tu as et
qu'un début pourquoi tu me casse la tête
comme ça je te casse rien du tout bébé
il veut simplement que les choses soient
claires tu connais la règle que j'ai
fixé dans cette maison tu dois choisir
où tu vas à l'école où tu vas travailler
et j'en ai rien à faire que ce soit du
ménage je m'en contrefiche des mamans je
suis patron je sais je sais c'est pas
toi le patron c'est long deux hôtes une
courant au cas où tu vas tu crois que
c'est réglé
victor est passioné groupe tu as quelque
chose à me dire il t'en fous tu
connaître mes rêves mes projets je sais
déjà ce que je veux faire de ma vie en
tout cas jamais je serai scotché
derrière un bureau des tofs de météo
je me suis cassé le cul pour nous offrir
la vie qu'on a pigé pas l'intention de
laisser tout [ __ ] en l'air